Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David,
P.. Here's a voicemail with a it's a it's
an interesting question. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: David, just want to suggest
what would have happened if Pence
had followed through on what Trump wanted him
to do? Where do you think we would be now?
Speaker 1: Thank you. Right? So Trump
wanted Pence to overturn the election.
And Pence said, I can't do that. I don't have the
power to do that constitutionally. And Pence was,
of course, correct. Let's play it out. Let's say
Pence was willing to do what Trump wanted him to
do, which is when Arizona tries to say, our
delegates vote for Joe, our electors vote for
Joe Biden. When Michigan tries to say our electors
vote for Joe Biden. Mike Pence, what they wanted
to do was to say, No, these are in dispute. We are
instead going to let a different slate of electors
vote instead of seven Republicans or seven
Democrats or however many it was from Arizona.
We're going to let these seven Republicans vote
instead, and they vote for Trump. It never would
have worked. It never would have worked. Those
alternate slates of electors, they let's see how
I can explain this. Determining who the rightful
electors are is not something that goes from the
Senate, from the House, from the Senate. You
know, the House of Representatives, from the
from Congress to the states. The states decide
who are the electors and send them to D.C. So.
If Arizona had seven Republicans get together
and say we are the electors which happened,
it happened in Arizona. Mike Pence doesn't
actually have the right to recognize any other
particular people, so it would have gone nowhere.
Now it would have caused chaos. I do believe that
if Mike Pence tried to do that, it would not have
worked. Joe Biden would still be president today,
but it would have riled up some Trumpists to
such a degree because they would have gotten
into their head that it was possible for
Pence to do it, that the riots likely would
have been dramatically worse and maybe would
have even lasted four days. That's my sense.
Let me know what you think would have happened if
Pence tried to do it. Make sure you are a member
so that you get access instantly to the bonus show
world famous award winning bonus show awards we
give out. Sure. But awards nonetheless. Sign up
right now at join Packman dot com and you can use
the coupon code Wow! Twenty two to save big
Unidentified: half of Avengers.